et action figure
axe
devant l'objectif de Frédéric Guillaume
Paruta Xavier interprété par José Dalma
et si l'eau est parfaitement habitué à
sa mission du jour pour l'autre c'est
une première
et les mettre au début mais une fois que
la première prise est faite la pression
reprend le contrôle du bateau et puis
c'est parti le court-métrage ABCD
raconte le quotidien d'un couple marié
deux enfants jusque la simple et sans
histoire une routine qu'un brutal
accident de la vie va venir bouleverser
sa problématique c'est que il ne s'est
ni lire ni écrire on se retrouve tout
seul après ce problème de santé assez
grave de sa femme Louise et qui est
interprété par Muriel hair dual et donc
il va s'avérer il va se retrouver seul à
se débrouiller avec ses son petit garçon
et sa fille et donc à être confronté à
ou de voir de classe par exemple à
rédiger des factures tout seul il sait
pas le faire j'ai besoin de toi regarde
ici et là tu te poses avec
le jeune réalisateur de 27 ans abonnés
peu de détails lui échappe le cap qui
dit je le vois moi par contre la fenêtre
il faut dire que le projet du tien à
coeur en Martinique 13% des 16,65 ans
seraient en situation d'illettrisme une
réalité entourée d'un tabou qui aimerait
bien voir lever Frédéric Guillaume
Paruta c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
discute qu'on parle et on a très peu
d'informations à ce sujet je me suis dit
mais pourquoi pas mettre les litigements
en lumière déjà ça va sensibiliser la
population qui est effectivement s'il y
a des périodes qui vivent dans la vidéo
tous les jours qui ne savent ni lire et
on est pas au courant parce qu'ils
arrivent à trouver des petits
stratagèmes pour éviter tout ce qui sera
lecture et culture l'éducation passe par
là la culture passe par là par le fait
de se voir lire le fait de savoir écrire
c'est un c'est une porte d'ouverture sur
soi-même l'écriture la lecture et le
savoir dire et le sac qui peut être par
la suite le savoir être
au total une trentaine de personnes
techniciens et comédiens participent au
tournage de ABCD le réalisateur espère
pouvoir sortir son court-métrage au
premier semestre 203